사나미 간다 오늘은 제 2의 도시
부산 광안리에
[음악]
[박수]
왔습니다서 요즘에 그 건물 공실이
굉장히 많은데 제가 건물 공실을
해결할 수 있는 방법을 좀
찾아왔습니다 그 방법을 해결해 주실
두 분을 모셨는데 광안리에서 브롱스는
가게 를 운영하시는 정현성 대표님과
정효성 대표님을 모셨습니다 안녕하세요
안녕하세요 안녕하세요 브롱스는 회사에
대해서 좀 간략하게 소개 좀
드리겠습니다 브롱스는 12년 된 수주
맥주 프랜차이즈 회사이고요 직접
맥주를 양조하고 물류로 유통하고
판매까지 하는 수식 열하는 회사라고
보시면 될 것 같습니다 저도 사실
브롱스는 회사를 되게 오래 전부터
알고 있었거든요 서울에서만 먹다가
어떻게 보면 여기 광안리에 처음 와서
봤을 정말 매장도 되게 넓고 다른
매장들과 좀 뭔가 차별화된 점이
있더라고요 그래서 여기 광안리점은 좀
어떻게 해서 만들게 되시 저희가
코로나 때 지경을 다 정리하게
됐었는데 서울이랑 부산 지역 쪽에
이제
지경을 다시
내자라는 생각을 하다가 광리 너무
뷰가 좋고 해가지고 여기로 결정하게
됐습니다 그리고 제가 미리 좀 정보를
봤을 때 기존 프랜차이즈 다 다른
점이 있다라고 하거든요 그래서 그런
부분에 대해서 좀 설명해 주시면 좋을
것 같습니다 외장 같은 경우 그니까
처음에 호텔 회장님께서이 1층 매장에
카페나 이런 거를 많이 내 주셨었는데
계속 패전하고 있는 와중에 저희가
입점을 하게 되었습니다 입점을 하면서
회장님께서 이제 수익률도 올라가고
여기가 광에서 이제 핫플레이스로
자리를 잡음으로서 건물 같이 상승해도
좀 기여를 한 부분이 있다고
생각합니다 신지 얼마나 되셨어요 3년
잠깐 안 됐습니다 아 2년 반 아마
작년 여름에도 한마 왔었는데 그때
진짜 사람이 엄청 많더라네 여름은
진짜 꽉 참다 그래서 여기서 사실이
광안대교 바라보는 비유가 너무
좋더라고요네 맞습니다 그래서 이게
어떻게 보면 지금 임대차 계약이 돼
있으신 거죠 예네 그래서 보통은 이제
임차 들어올 때 뭔가 그런 문제점들이
많이 있으실 것 같아요 어떤 부분이
제일 일단 임대인과 임차인 내
이해관계가 좀 다른 부분들 그래서
서로 신뢰하기 전에 이제 걱정스러운
부분들이나 이런게 이제 임차인도
있지만 뭐 임대인 분들도 당연히
고민이 있으실 거라고 생각을 합니다
코텔 회장님이랑 건물주 분이랑 대화를
많이 해봤는데
고충들이 있으시더라고요 상가임대차
보호법이 그지 뭐 그 부분을 좀
해결하기 위한 좀 사업 모델 같은
거를 고민을 좀 해봤습니다 저 그
사업 모델에 대해서 구체적으로
말씀해주세요 일단 건물주 분들께서
고민하셨던 부분이 월세 인상률에 대한
부분이라든지 임차인에 대한 권리금
이슈라는 계약 기간 보전이라는 뭐
여러 가지 이유가 있으셨다고 저희가
이번에 만든 모델은 건물주분께서
인테리어 익스테리어 기기 설비 등을
투자를 해 주시면 저희가 12년간
매장을 운영한 노하우로 매출을
발생시키고 거기에서 이제 매출에
12% 수익 쉐어하는 모델로 만든게
이번에 모 입니다이 모델에서 이제
상가 임대차 보호법에서 문제를 해결할
수 있는게 투자를 건물주분께서 직접
해 주시기 때문에 임차인의 권리금
이슈라는 돈 들이고 들어온게 아니기
때문에 계약기간 이슈가 없습니다
건물주분께서 원하시는만큼만 일을
운영을 하셔도 되고 월세 인상률 같은
경우는 매출이 상승하면서 이제 수익
쉐어하는 모델이기 때문에 월세
인상률에 대한 이슈도 없을 것
같습니다 이데 어떻게 보면 상생하는
모델인데 요즘에 워낙 공실이 많아요
뭐 몇 개월 뭐 길게는 제 몇 년이
비어 있는 거 들이 되게 많거든요
근데 이제 건물주 입장에서는 임대
주기에도 조금 애매하고 임대 잘못
줬다가 나중에 못 내보내는 경우도
많이 있긴 해가지고 방금 말씀하신
그런 전략들이 제가 봤을 때 앞으로
좀 더 가감을 받지 않을까이 생각을
좀 하고 있습니다 제가 알고 있기로는
그 양조장도 있으시다고죠 예 양조장도
경기도 포천에서 저희가 직접 양조한
맥주를 매장에서 판매를 하는 거죠이
지금 영상을 보고 계신 분들 중에
건물주 분들이 되게 많거든요 조건들이
있을까요 뭐 서울 지역에 좀
집중하려고 하세요 아니면 뭐
지역적으로 일단 처음은 서울 지역에
있는 매장이 나오는게 더 좋다고
생각을 합니다 광한리뿐만 아니라 이제
서울에도 오피스나 이런데 저희가
들어갈 계획을 갖고 있어서 그쪽
건물주 분들께서 연락 주시면 좋죠
저네 그러면은 서울 지역에 오시는
거고 일단은 층은 이제 1층 예 제일
좋으신 거죠 1일 제 좋습니다 한
최소 평수가 있을까요 평수는 이렇게
넓은 공간이네
많지 않잖아요 30평 이상 그리고 뭐
50평 정도 뭐 그리고 그 이상
평수도 운영을 할 수 있습니다 어떻게
보면은 건물주 입장에서는 운영이 제일
문제기도 하잖아요 이제 운영을 또
직접 다 해 주시면 실제로 지경점
운영을 12년 동안 해 왔고 일단
여기 서울에 이제 지경점 그니까
건물주 공동 사업 모델로 내게 되면은
여기 부산에 있는 직경의 직원들의 몇
명을 파견을 아예 위에서 근무 시킬
예정입 경 있는 친구들이 운영하기
때문에 또 안정적으로 운영될 거라
생각합니다 어떻게 보면 되게 좀 좋은
기회라고 생각을 하거든요 그냥 비어져
있는 거보다 어찌됐든 이렇게 마음
맞는 그니까 좋은 테넌트를 딱 드린
다음에 뭐 같이 사업하는 방식이 너무
좋은 거 같아서 그런 것도 되게
궁금해하실 것 같아 비용적인 부분
30평 정도에 차린다고 하면 대략 뭐
인테리어나 뭐 이런 비용이 대략 어느
정도 될거요 근데 이게 건물마다
스펙이 달라서 정확하게 말씀드릴 수는
없는데 2억 정도
그죠 예를 어 건태 깨끗하다 그 뭐
철거비가 빠지기 때문에 뭐 그런
것들은 근데 직접 봐야 좀 알 수
있는 부분이 될 거 같아요 건물마다
너무 컨디션이 다르기 때문에 그냥
대략 참고하시면 될 거 같고 여기가
장사가 될 곳인지 안 될 곳인지네
저희 입장에서도 운영을 통해서 이제
수익을 내야 되고 그리고 그 매출에
이제 수익 쉐어를 건물 주게 해야
되기 때문에 그러니까 뭐 무조건
매장을내는 거보다는 서로 윈윈할 수
있는 상권 파악을 해야 되기 때문에
아무데나 입점할 생각은 없고요 문의를
주시면 저희가 직접 방문해서 아 상건
부속도 하고 건물 컨디션도 확인하고
싶습니다 저도 이제 주변에서 보면
운영해 주겠다고 하고 막 이렇게
비용을 중간에 챙겨가는 경우가 되게
많거든요 근데 이제 어떻게 보면라는
건물이 있다라고 하면 된다 안 된다
이렇게 얘기하는게 사실 되게 크긴
하거든요 보통은 그냥 다 된다 그러고
막 안 되는 장소들도 막 그렇게
해가지고 건물주 이렇게 해가지고 하는
경우가 많은데 프로세스를 다시 한번
좀 정리해 보면은 어떤 주소인지 미리
알려 주시면 그거를 좀 사전에
검토하신 다음에 된다 안
된다네 얘기를 해 주시고 대략 매출도
계산이 될까요 어 상권 저희가 그래도
가맹점을 들어간 경험이 많기 때문에이
상권에서는이 정도 매출이 나올거다이
정도 평소에서 뭐이 정도는
대략적으로는 예상이 가능합니다 그리고
그걸 바탕으로 저희도 수익을 내야
되는 부분이라 이해 관계가 이제
같아지는 거기 때문에 저희가 무조건
다 된다 뭐 이렇게 얘기할 수 없는
거죠 건물주 분들 중에서도 하고 싶어
하시는 분들 있거든요 그동안 뭐
10년 넘게 운영하시면서 싸움
노하우들도 있으시니까 만약에 뭐 이런
거 좀 필요하다라고 하시면은 뭐 연락
주시면은 너무 좋을 것 같습니다 지금
여기 앞에 있는 곳도 그 양조장에서
직접 만들어 주셔 가지고 뭐 회사랑
같이 만들었는데 사실 제가 술을 잘
못 해요
하는데 어 근데 제 입맛에 맞은
맥주거리 되게 반응이 좋더라고요 좀
정리해 보자면 서울시에 좀 이렇게
진출할 계획이고 평수는 한 최소
30평 이상예 1층 만약에 공실이
있으신 건물주분 있으면은 언제든지
연락 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 빌딩은
역시 글산
[음악]
k